welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and the Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
Super Bowl trailer finally gave us a
look at the method behind the high
evolutionaries Madness but how did that
Madness lead
reject 89p13 AKA rocket and why is
Rocket's origin so gosh dang traumatic
in the MCU so let's dive into just how
the madman Herbert Windham created The
Mad Mambo rocket turret gang so the new
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer
promises to finally show us the super
messed up origins of one rocket in the
MCU and it's one origin that
unfortunately involves a lot of animal
abuse as shots of baby rocket being
Shackled poked and prodded and tattooed
as the high evolutionaries subject 89p13
and this happens as the high
evolutionary explains that his overall
goal behind everything that he does is
to create a perfect Society a notion
that Rocket says is BS he didn't want to
make things perfect he just hated things
the way they uh according to Rocket the
high evolutionary is a man who is
chronically unhappy with the way
evolutionary is playing out in the
cosmos and is on a personal mission to
make his version of the perfect Society
filled with the most perfectly evolved
life forms but unfortunately when it
comes to biological scientific
advancements the beings that suffer the
most those are usually the Lab Rats
which is exactly what rocket originally
was in the MCU like James Gunn has been
saying for years now though he's known
as Rocket Raccoon in the comics rocket
in the MCU is actually not an earth
raccoon but rather a genetically
modified and cybernetically enhanced
alien rat subject
89p13 calls itself rocket the result of
illegal genetic and cybernetic
experiments on a lower life form even
though this looks like a baby raccoon in
the trailer this is actually an alien
rat it's not a raccoon and this is very
much in line with the high evolutionary
from the comics as the scientist Herbert
Windham used to experiment on rats in
his basement before having a scientific
breakthrough in evolution and evolving
those rats into bipedal higher life
forms with sentience labeling these
newly evolved creatures as his new men
because he sort of viewed himself like a
Celestial God type B making newer and
better versions of life and at one point
he put all of these new mana on a
completely new planet that he created
himself called counter Earth which was
originally intended to be his upgraded
mirror version of Earth basically a
planet of evolved alien rats at the high
evolutionary made to look like bipedal
animals that the Guardians landed on in
that first trailer like that planet is
counter Earth these are all new men and
this is why yandu were first to rock it
as a rat repeatedly in Guardians 2 after
doing his homework on him after meeting
him in the first movie hey there rat I
know them scientists what made you never
gave a rat's ass about you I ain't done
nothing right my whole damn life rat
Rocket Raccoon in the MCU appears to be
a prototype version of the new man race
one of the High evolutionaries Lab Rats
that he opened up and replaced their
body parts with cybernetic enhancements
in order for a four-legged rat alien to
walk upright after he evolved their
intellect I think it's basically like a
two-step process first he evolves those
alien rats intellects genetically and
then when their brains turn on he messes
with their skeletal structure with
cybernetic enhancements until he gets
them to walk upright and this is why
Rocket's back looks so gnarly as he gets
changed into his prison uniform in
Guardians 1. like that's all that metal
keeping his vertebrae straight this is
the significance behind the bloody
scalpel in the trailer and Rocket being
tied up for surgery he is about to
undergo the incredibly painful trauma of
having his body torn apart repeatedly in
order to evolve well I didn't ask to get
made
I didn't ask to be torn apart and put
back together over and over and turned
into some
some little monster and we also get a
peek as to the role that the high
evolutionary could have given to Rocket
in Guardians 2 as Peter and Rocket argue
over who was the better pilot what are
you doing I've been flying this rig
since I was 10 years old I was
cybernetically engineered the pilot of
spacecraft two cybernetically engineered
to be a douchebag with rocket saying
that he was cybernetically engineered
here to Pilot a spacecraft I believe
that this was him alluding to how the
high evolutionary created him to be one
of his Pilots for his giant spaceship
laboratory that we see in the Guardians
flying up to in the new trailer the high
evolutionary needs a Workforce to make
his Cosmic level Evolution dreams a
reality in early experiments like rocket
and his love interest Laila were
unfortunately likely that very sentient
slave labor that he developed because
that big ass spaceship is not going to
fly itself and I think rocket calls
himself rocket because he was made to
fly the high evolutionaries rocket a
rocket that I have a feeling was made
out of a chunk of rock from the same
Mount wondercore from Doctor Strange too
because in the comics the high
evolutionary constructed his spaceship
in that mountain before he took off to
the stars and hey guys we've got a new
place to buy the coolest stuff nerd
riot.shop we took our merch shop gave it
a glow up and added a bunch of cool new
clothing and gear hand-picked by the
team at new Rockstar if you've been
obsessing over the last of us as hard as
we have make sure to toss a lost in the
darkness T into your go bag before your
next post-apocalyptic Cross Country Road
trip and we have a very stylish line of
quantum Mania teas hoodies and beanies
featuring cool designs inspired by the
upcoming Marvel film and I even came up
with one of these designs myself Based
On Da Vinci's Vitruvian man but with
Kang in there instead of a naked Italian
dude we're really excited that they are
available ahead of the release of the
film so that you can order now and wear
them to the theater on opening night you
can exchange high fives with other
members of the gang gang in the
concession line because that's how the
Kang gang rolls and make sure you throw
up the Kang gang gang signs so to get
your hands on those and some very
stylish new Rockstar's logo designs head
to nerd riot.shop today and keep an eye
out for our upcoming Mandalorian season
3 designs they're going to be really
great so join the riots over at nerd
riot.shop but anyways though we know how
they walk uprights the question of how
the high evolutionary triggered the
evolution of small alien rats to turn
them into sentine creatures Still
Remains but I believe that this is a
question that is answered in both
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 and the
eternals film as it also sort of answers
another burning question why the hell
did raccoon steal those annulax
batteries from the mega evolved
Sovereign race like why the hell did you
do that in the first place well I
believe that Rockets stole those
batteries because he was already
familiar with this type of yellow
Energy's evolutionary effect on the
nervous system when he was being
experimented on by the high evolutionary
and he like literally immediately hated
The Sovereign because they acted like
the conceded elitist penises much like
the high evolutionary appears to act in
the trailer he was so conceited because
he's like I have the most evolved
intellect of the world but nobody could
talk to me I'm floating I'm doing a
little better taking in the air because
I'm so sad because if you look back to
rocket after the Guardians defeat that
tentacle monster in Guardians 2 he picks
up on the sovereign's batteries and
observes it like he's seen that type of
energy before what are they called again
anilax batteries but there were
thousands of units a piece which is why
the Sovereign hired us to protect them
and later when the Guardians need a bomb
to destroy ego notice how he
demonstrates this knowledge of this
Sovereign Evolution energy on living
beings when he won the Guardians about
the harbulary bombs effect on the
nervous system cause a chain reaction
throughout his entire nervous system
meaning what the entire planet will
explode I think rocket knew of that
coming chain reaction to ego's nervous
system because he underwent a similar
reaction himself through this Evolution
energy that The Sovereign race have used
to upgrade themselves and their society
as well as make the ultimate being of
peak Evolution known as Adam Warlock
whose very body is brimming with that
same Evolution energy as he flies about
in the trailer and have a feeling that
this type of golden energy is the very
same type of energy that powers every
Eternal which is why the Deviant Pro was
slowly evolving every time he absorbed
this harbulary energy out of the
eternals First with Ajax
[Music]
and then with Gilgamesh
I understand now but yeah that's
basically it I believe the high
evolutionary used this yellow Evolution
energy to evolve Rocket Raccoon and all
the people of counter Earth from Alien
rats and then tore them apart and
outfitted their bodies with cybernetic
technology to be able to be the ultimate
beings and tools of research and warfare
for his purposes which is why Rocket
Raccoon is so damn good at flying ships
and making weapons literally out of
scraps I love you so much rocket please
don't die please don't die he's totally
gonna die but please don't die he's
totally gonna die God please don't kill
him James God I love him so much but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
Master retainment on Twitter if you want
to see me tweet some really fun theories
and really weird [__] but more
importantly you can follow into
rockstars wherever you are on the social
media and of course do not forget to
subscribe to the Deep dive which is
launching this weekend it's our second
amazing new channel that we've just
started and Eric Voss has tons of new
and amazing videos for you to watch so
subscribe to the Deep dive today but
again thank you guys so much for
watching this video I love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
thank you